I was reading on Yahoo I think it was
the other day that Connie Britton the
actress looks back on the fact that I
think Renee Zellweger got the role of
Dorothy Boyd in Jerry Maguire oh okay
and it was it was fascinating to look at
it she kind of talked about you know
just maybe why she didn't get it and how
her life has been since the 90s yeah
have you thought about what life would
have been like if you hadn't gotten the
first you know Last Exorcism oh yes have
you thought okay oh yes all the time
because every day I'm I'm it's literally
a privilege to be doing what I do yes I
mean getting getting Last Exorcism Part
1 broke me onto the scene it it was it
was I mean as an actress it's the
ultimate opportunity to build two
characters I got a chance to build Nell
and then to build abalam the devil and
you know because of that film and I was
nominated for Spirit Award an MTV Award
and the audience support was so massive
that it's allowed me to do the sequel
but also to cross over into other genres
you know I I do also study a lot of The
Groundlings my mom is one of the
founding members of The Groundlings and
I loved that I was able to jump into a
romantic comedy called the bounce back
you know I have two action films coming
out called the marine and sparks you
know that's totally physical I studied
Muay Thai to prep for those and
inhabited these other characters and
also my Cambridge Shakespeare training
came in part for a film that's coming
out called chasing Shakespeare which
will also be premiering with the
bounce-back at South by Southwest and
you know getting a chance to you to play
all these roles and make all these
transformations is is a privilege and
it's the best part of acting so yes I
mean the horror genre what it is now is
so incredible because it allows you to
be broken onto the scene as and as an
actress well having grown up with comedy
yes your mom
Groundlings how is it for a beautiful
woman and I'm putting you on the spot
here with Elle to be in a comedy in a
communion because I think a lot of times
women are intimidated men are
intimidated by a beautiful woman and
then to see them as funny they don't
know where to categorize them they don't
know how to deal with it but then you
think back to a Mae West and she pulled
that off
right right how are you able to do that
at the same time because it seems like
it's sometimes people get scared and
it's oh wow well first of all thank you
uh second of all um you know it's it's
great to jump like I love testing myself
that way I actually we wrapped on the
last exorcism and then two nights later
I was on set filming for the bounce back
this romantic comedy and you know it was
it was so much it was so funny because
you know Here I am
for the last exorcism covered in blood
or mud or you know doing whatever I'm
doing restrained you know going full
hilt do math and couldn't you know
levitating and you know then further
romantic comedy I have fake eyelashes
and lip gloss and beautiful dresses and
I just you know for the first part of it
was like oh wait I so if I explain I
love you I don't have to do a backbend I
I get to tell you you know it's just I
mean it's it's that wonderful jump you
get a make as an actress
you